oh cool let's just rock right man see
you good to see ya nice to finally meet
you you know it's very nice to meet you
of follow G calling you for a very long
time
a couple things I think you know and
it's funny cuz this podcast has become
like a I don't know like it's become
like the Australian pakka I have so many
Australians on the show I just put up G
no Paul de Gelder yeah I just put him up
the other day like now I'm staring at
another super wrist really dude you know
I don't like I want to be a an honorary
Australia what do they call it that you
have the Oh a yeah that's like being
like being knighted yeah yeah well
they're poles are pulls stories it's
amazing crazy right yeah
our bumped into him and Bondi he was
when I'm not sure he's still living
there but he's you know his attitude to
and in towards the story it's just
phenomenal yeah I mean his ability to
kind of transcend that experience and be
this inspirational figure like I and I
said this in the podcast like I I knew
his story was crazy but I didn't have a
grip on like what a great storyteller he
is and how inspiration yeah this is the
way that he tells the story but you
arrived from the hospital honey this
guy's yeah so yeah he lives here now
he lives in Venice he's having a go here
he does all the Shark Week stuff for
Discovery Channel and leaving a name for
himself here so you know yeah you've got
a big following in Australia very well
we love all to ultra sports we love
swimming Shane I mean I don't think
Americans really appreciate or can
understand the reverence with which you
know the swimmer is perceived in
Australian theatre yeah it's a it's
definitely our number one Olympic sport
and it's you know in in the Europe they
probably send their kids to soccer
training or you know learn soccer and in
Australia learn to swim
it's a first sport pretty much right
soon as in you know infant aquatics is
like you know it's not compulsory in
every school but it will be pretty soon
I think so learn to swim with the first
sport of it on lines yeah right away
like as soon as you can walk right yeah
but you're you're originally from Poland
right yeah so I'm good pretty
interesting story I was born in Poland
my parents my dad worked for the polish
consulate so we traveled a lot growing
up so I moved to India once when I was
one and a half I spent so I actually
learned to swim in India for a country
that's kind of probably more known for
its cricket and not a big swimming
powerhouse no but it's funny kind of how
history repeats itself because I'm I'm
living in Bali most of my time and I go
to a little bit of a country club my
kids spend most of their life and I
country come yeah so very much the way I
grew up and you know dad used to drop us
off on the way to work and pick us up
eight hours later and you know the only
thing I could do is just play in the
water and have fun and that's how I sort
of got this infinity kind of like this
affinity with the water that and I just
akan describes yeah early on so you you
you spend most of the time in Bali and
then the rest of the time in Melbourne
yeah so I sort of split my time between
my business which I've got a skincare
company now and we sort of got a skin
fitness range of products and then we
also enough yeah my kids live in Bali so
I split my time between Valium today
yeah do they go to the green school they
do do they were going to go and day
every day I hear about the green school
I have a very good friend here in in
Malibu and he splits his time between
Bali in here and he just left again and
both his kids go to the green school
yeah I've got a really good friend who's
a meditation teacher named Charlie
Knowles it's got a whole bunch of kids
that go to school there so I'm always
seeing photos and little videos of what
goes on there and then our mutual friend
David's by the time they're yeah and so
I'm very familiar with what goes on
there I mean that place is unbelie--
John Hardy founded it the jeweler and
it's yeah it's quite insane you know in
terms of for me I've seen the
development in my kids the growth in
terms of their confidence and
it's just it's just different approach
to education which you know they kind of
yeah it's it's it's a community it's
very cold like sometimes but it's right
like well my friend Chris set is said
like yeah like you drop your kids off
from school and then all the parents
hang out like nobody's working like what
is going on there none there's no walls
like it's all outdoor education yeah
it's you know it's basically
self-sustaining world they go to water
to her barn so yeah it's a really good
to sort of from my kids and especially
my son way he's got a bit of a speech
impediment and he he he was really shy
especially socially and within three
years he's now in the narrating the
school play in front of many hundreds of
kids and he you know like he's got this
air of confidence but it's still you
know I think it's just the school's
empowered and to believe in himself and
he's still got a beautiful personality
so yeah so it's definitely it gets them
kind of street ready in the sense right
yeah it's super cool it's really cool
all right well let's talk swimming okay
so you grow you grow up you know
basically with wet hair yeah I mean were
you were you were you like a talent from
the get-go did you know like early on
like oh man this is like my thing or
were you just playing a whole bunch of
sports now I definitely played a lot of
different sports but for me swimming or
something that because when I travel as
I explained earlier went from India back
to Poland Germany Canada and that
eventually moved to Australia and all
these things were changing in my life
and from languages you know school
environments and these you know
circles of friends etc and the only
thing that kind of remained constant for
me was my swimming it's kind of like if
I could join any squad in any country
and kind of fit in did you learn all the
languages everywhere you live yeah
pretty much started to learn English and
German and I'm still learning English
actually polish was your first language
yes so yes it's art for me swimming was
something that I was aren't used to
gravitate to because I was kind of good
at it and it kind of man you know give
me gave me acceptance again around
and you know in the circle of friends I
was in but but yet my tennis is actually
my family's actually probably a tennis
family my sister played professionally
and so the my dad so I was II I tried I
didn't kind of have the temperament for
chance of being a sprinter I sort of um
yeah too much time to think on the
tennis court but um yeah so I definitely
um you know it was something that I yeah
I had a really good sort of strong idea
that I wanted to pursue it for the Aged
and and how does it work in Australia is
it like a club program kind of thing or
is it through the schools like I know
once you kind of you get noticed as an
emerging talent there's all these you
know there's all this structure that
comes into play but yeah look it's still
very amateur it still comes through in
traditional club you know a club
structure and then there is state
funding they stayed in institute of
sport and then there's the obviously the
overarching Sports Commission who sort
of facilitate through the Australians to
make programs but it's still very much
you know the land the swim schools feed
the swimming clubs and then you can
obviously join the some of the late
squads that still exist but it's still
predominantly a club club set up and
yeah we're still pretty a small country
and we've we've actually in the middle
of our more famous trials at the moment
all right yeah I said but yeah it's
still you know for us it's it's do a
pretty simple simple process does
Australian Institute of Sport still
exist I just remember when I was a kid
man what goes on there I was 15 I was
tapped on the shoulder by two guys one
was Gennady to rescue as the coach of
Alex pop off and the other one was Jim
Farley he came from Etobicoke in Toronto
and so those hopper guns team yeah yeah
that's right in the majority before that
right yes it was sort of at the age of
15 and they said ah we want you to move
to Canberra and live there in the
lead-up to Sydney and you know they
already were identifying who was
could be good and could be a good fit
for the relay and and for me you know
the you know the coach of the greatest
sprinter of all time didn't asked me to
train with him so yeah a year later I
packed up the bags and mom and dad drove
me up the highway up to up to Canberra
from Melbourne so huh oh yes I moved out
of home and made that sacrifice to
slowly pursue
swimming any of the Institute is you
know people sort of they don't they're
not very complimentary about Canberra
it's it's a pretty boring place but
that's what Paul's from he was telling
me a little bit about what it was like
there I mean it's definitely different
from what you imagined yeah Melbourne
and Sydney - absolutely it's look it's
it's military to town and where it's now
it's got a universe couple good
universities rather for us it was ideal
for what we were doing you know just
training a great facilities still the
facilities far superior to any other
complex and in in Australia so now it's
more used for there's no more resident
program at the Institute of Sport it's
more sort of four camps etc similar to
Colorado Springs actually aha yeah and
does it work the same in terms of
Olympic Trials and qualifying for the
team as it does in the states where you
have a meet and you you get first or
second and you go and yeah pretty much
and you know what traditionally we have
our trials two or three months prior to
the big meet you know having having seen
the success of the US team this time we
were actually having the trials from the
come off games only five weeks out of
the coma range so I think it makes sense
it's I think there's a lot of you know
if opportunity for error and you know if
a lot of things can happen between you
know with right now and say two or three
months time so I think eliminates the
there's always there's always gray in a
black and white snow right well it's a
super tricky equation to me for people
that list they're listening who aren't
familiar with swimming I mean you
basically bust your ass for nine months
or however long and then and then you
taper down for a couple weeks
yeah you know maybe a month if you're a
sprinter like you I don't know what your
you know particular protocol is and
you've hang it all out to dry in that
one meet and if it's trials that's
usually as competitive if not more
competitive more hyper
than the Olympics itself make the team
and then you're looking at five weeks
yeah and that's a very difficult kind of
thing to approach because you can't just
coast for five weeks you got to kind of
build back up but you can't build back
out or too much and some people hit it
right and some people miss it altogether
yeah they'd like lost your Olympic
performances yeah exactly
look we've tried it and I think it look
I think swimming does we only have that
big meet once every four years limp
again Olympic Games and you know the
world champs are on there every second
year but it is you know we have to - big
hit out a year in Australia not like the
u.s. we've got the NC - a system and you
can really race competitively and have
really good sort of hit outs regulate
whereas australia's have struggled
finding competitions being so
geographically so far removed from
everything but you know it's you know
we're getting there i was very fortunate
that my era was you know had the likes
of Thorpe and Hackett and Perkinson and
know Neil and Samantha Reilly and you
know at least with joints and they'd be
Trickett then you know it almost they
could have probably got away with not
racing as much but the you know the
depth of the in the world of swimming
has changed I think you know Eastern
European countries that have come up a
lot and also the Asian countries
assuming really well as well so um it's
a different picture - when I was me but
you were a member like a you know a
gold-plated member of the golden era of
Australian swimming I mean that that
period of time I mean was the ascendancy
of Australian swimming I mean you guys
were a powerhouse it was unbelievable
yeah you know I don't know 98 2008 or
something yeah - six and that Sydney
Olympics was really kind of a coming-out
party for Australian swimming I mean
you've been up you know a global power
for a long time but that was something
else altogether yeah it was really like
it was quite something yeah you know to
get to get an Olympic Games in home soil
for Australia the one prior to that was
a 56 in Melbourne and you know we you
know the others have so much pride in
their sport it's a so fanatical similar
to see you guys and it
it was a magical two weeks in in Sydney
the weather was fantastic there was no
traffic everyone was happy and smiling
so I don't know you left the Olympic the
Olympic kind of fever but the talent
pool that you had was unbelievable yeah
you look it was you know it was hockey's
first Olympic gold was in he broke the
world record in the 400 and won the
silver and the 200 but wonderful by one
in the foot by two with me and yeah we
had you know as Kieran's last swim but I
you know he had the likes of Suzy
O'Neal's tool you know the winning gold
and it's run at freestyle and you know
just an an amazing team and it sort of
was led by these guys we had a really
good mix of up-and-coming you know the
likes of Hackett and thought which I
mentioned but you know the Suzy Ernie
linkage on the on the latter end of
their careers and sort of myself and
Jeff Hugo and couple others slotted
right there in the middle and yeah I was
very fortunate to as I said to have you
know the Olympics on home soil was just
phenomenal and you know oh it's part of
the race that you know I'm going on in
Australia for playing an air guitar oh
yeah I know we're gonna get in that we
have I had Anthony Irvin in here and I
was like I gotta get Clem in here to
hear the first hand but I think like
that's that is my before I met you
you know like I'm like that's my visual
image of you like I just remember that's
like imprinted seared into my brain like
that moment so I mean maybe walk us
through that story for people that are
new to show do yeah sure sure so look I
mean you guys that the Americans had
never been beaten in the football on
freestyle relay and then history unto
that moment so the inception was 1972 I
think of the event so yeah it's and you
know through the NCTA program and you
know you're just so strong and realized
you know how to race them how to put the
team together heats and finals and we we
had one guy Red Hawk who was racing in
the 50 freestyle was from the Auburn
system and Auburn University and he kind
of uh he'd trying to help
helped us how to how could we put
together a team that could challenge his
superpower and the
on freestyle relay and we had myself who
was you know I was the highest strength
freestyle third and I'm number third in
the world
Ian Thorpe was a 400 freestyle but had
some potential Chris father was our
oldest tights man and Ashley Callas was
a rookie so we really didn't have
attained that was you know like in the
American team had pretty much I think we
had Gary Hall who's the number one
talkers and Tony Irvin and Jason Lee and
those are more prominent names at the
time yeah absolutely yeah and look how
I'm still in it's funny how sport you've
realized house put sported for us it was
everything you know like I was for us
winning that relay it changed my life
you know people still walk down the
street and do this I'm sure we should we
should point out that you broke the
world record in 100 free leading off
that relay yeah it's to this point it's
still my best ever swim you know I won
48 one yeah so it I just um look we
basically that this is the strategy we
you know we had we basically wanted to
try and get elite somehow and and then
get the Americans to over I stood each
leg and then I eat guys aren't used to
coming second very often so it was kind
of it threw them off the game but now we
might be alike so it's sort of and we
just our psychology was really just to
make sure that last 20 meters into the
wall was really strong
so we're just thinking we're focusing on
back ending every single leg and and if
you look at the splits after the second
the second third fourth swimmer the guys
are always turning first at the the
50-meter end and we're turning first of
the day and the honda mater and services
was just a real tactical event that sort
of fell our way but it was yeah a little
too to be honest and to give Gary credit
he's an amazing ambassador for the sport
he was the first one to shake my hand
after the event and I'm actually still
in touch with him these days and you
know that
you know 18 years ago it's it's yeah
well its history but it's it's sort of
shaped this 40 at a great rivalry with
pop up that I used to watch and in 96
when you know he he was amazing because
he brought entertainment that's why
getting this you know really bold you
know kind of outspoken Muhammad Ali type
Garrett yeah and just for people that
are listening what happened was he went
on record he told some of the reporter
we're gonna smash the Aussies like you
know like ours or something yeah and so
when you guys won you're all in Sophie's
ideas I yeah so was one of those moments
so we with it still regarded for us and
the Olympic history is one of them
that's one of the one of the interesting
that you just said like you guys really
focused on you know the last part of
those 100-meter legs and one thing that
you are unique in is you have this very
interesting way that you finish your
races you're the only person I've ever
seen who lunches into the wall with a
couple underwater dolphin kick yeah way
in I've never seen anyone else do that
like where did that come from and why do
you think that that was like your
advantage yeah look I trained a lot with
I'm obviously Gennady turetsky being my
coach and initially I started swimming
trying to emulate Alex and I wanted to
have this beautiful high elbow recovery
and but I very soon found out that it
was I wasn't 64 right I didn't have his
physique and I started I as a drill we
started swimming we used to have dolphin
kick Freddie start with your head up it
was kind of a water polo drill just to
it sort of emphasizes good dynamic
recovery and and then I was and then we
have another drill just windmill drill
with straight on freestyle and then we
just thought of a combining the both of
them as a drill only I'm dolphin kick
with straight arms just to really
emphasize each stroke and throwing your
hand forward etc and I started just my
first time I did it I just felt like I
was floating from stroke to stroke each
kick kind of gave me extra inertia from
stroke to stroke and
and you can only got me in like 24
points something for a 53 and I was like
this is this could actually work and you
know and my legs were my my weakness and
and probably psychologically I always
used to think I hurt my leg stronger I
hurt my legs than going and you know
them less when I wasn't psychologically
strong in my Rice's I normally should
probably used to kick earlier than I
needed to it but yeah so became a good
wife and me to keep momentum into the
wall mm-hmm
and why do you think no one else started
doing this well I think it's you know at
that transition from freestyle kick to
dolphin kick after laureates awkward
yeah so I'm I know that I know that
Michael Phelps tried it a couple times
of the last Olympic Trials and but I
think yeah when when he got to rear he
went back to his original stroke so yeah
look it's you know I had to be
innovative you know I don't I'm no not
much taller than the average not much
stronger than the average and so I
strong you know let's get that
straight but I think you I think you you
innovated in another way which is that
you you did have this like straight arm
recovery and your butterfly as well and
now when you look at swimming now
everybody's doing that
yeah the swimmers look weird like it
doesn't look like I'm like what are they
doing that doesn't look anything like
yeah the way that we used to swim and
you know I'm older than you but I was at
a I went and did a swim practice with
Conor Dwyer down at USC with Johnny and
check yeah and got to swim with all
these guys and like they're all doing
they're all doing that yeah you know
yeah put your head down I was always
thought to have my head you know like
the water line here and there like like
the technique aspect they figured out so
many things yeah and I think your
straight arm recovery was on very
unusual at the time yeah yeah okay with
and that's actually touching back on the
institute of sport you know it was
Australia semi had to be resourceful
because we didn't have hundreds of
swimmers coming through and we used to
fall back a lot on fish I know you know
physiology and biomechanics and you know
and nutrition so way we kind of had to
use all everything that
available to us to get the most out of
our team so yeah and you know I tested
artist of the strike a number of times
and and yeah for me it definitely gave
me I wouldn't say an advantage but it
just sort of kept me when it's
especially when the suits came in and I
had had a stronger sort of more aligned
core I could sort of keep my momentum
into the wall but yeah as you said
pretty much all the sprinters are doing
it now yeah it's crazy so what like 21
World Records how many World Records
something with Olympic medals and then
you had that crazy World Championships
were you won like I don't know
everything pretty much right yeah you
know at the time after speech was the
first time anyone had won seven so and
then obviously you know Michael came
along after that right rewrote
everything but yeah is there is there a
particular performance that stands out
as your favorite or does it all bleed
together experience no I think for me
that week in Perth was as an individual
performance was I was probably not my
most defying because it's sort of
already ate me a 90 engine yeah I had
broken the world record in 100 fly in
October and their World Championships
were in January and I wasn't yeah I was
in great shape physically and also I was
still pretty pretty fresh I hadn't been
you know I spent only a few years with
with Alex and and I was really sort of
targeting the the 200 free and I managed
to win that on the first night but and I
started getting really tired towards the
end of the meet and you know I qualified
only for 100 fly final and it's the
first time that are in that week I
thought that you know I'm not gonna I've
got a couple more swims to gone I'm
gonna even finish this mate so I fell
yet I stood up and then and won that in
a pretty close to word record time as
well so that was a wake that kind of oh
my you know it they're ahead the
training with Gennady and the Mars we
used to saw after 100 days a week we'd
spent 60 miles awake at times and it all
started really paying off just you know
falling back into that my yeah I either
mentality of every time the gun went I
would
I didn't really paste myself from heats
of farmers whatever pretty much and it
all just started coming coming into into
interplay so what did you learn from
ganar d like what what is the what made
him a great coach I think it was a
really interesting coach because he had
um he was able to adjust not only his
approach in terms of the sessions what
we were doing for every swimmer because
we are all different physically you know
and we all recover differently and you
know we we all need different
stimulation and we have that so he was
able to get the most out of all the
swimmers and even creating five
different workouts for five different
swimmers on on the board and then one
session but then also being able to
mentally get he would treat myself
different to Alex of course and then
Matt Dunn who was also my training
partner he'd have a completely slightly
different approach so that communication
without with the athlete was probably
his key you know like I knew that you
know he'd probably leave me alone for
most of my warm-ups and just appear out
of them out of the blue just for the for
the right time when he needed to see me
and he had a great eye he could probably
watch me for ten seconds I dive in in
the warm-up you could tell you how I
felt
right right right and so and I think
that having that real great intuition so
he was well educated but had a great eye
for the sport it sounds very similar to
to where Bob Bowman trauma like I was
telling you earlier I was listening to
podcast Michael Gervais he's
interviewing Bob Bowman Michael Phelps
his coach he's also coached a number of
other Olympians and he's talking about
the importance of the coach athlete
relationship and how it's a partnership
and how you really have to individuate
you know amongst these different people
and how he could tell you know soon as
one of his athletes walked on the deck
yeah just look in their eye and he you
know like what kind of workout they were
gonna have because they're it is such an
intimate you know close-knit thing yeah
and trying to crack like okay like what
you know how is you know what makes
Michael tick like what's gonna motivate
ya you come at them hard you come out
I'm soft like that's going to be
different
for every athlete and I think it's you
know look when you're when you're
dealing with the elite of the elite you
got like 10 people you're coaching it's
one thing you're a club coach you got 50
kids you know five and Elayne or
something like yeah it's a different
thing yeah yeah yeah the more that you
can understand you know what the sort of
psychological makeup yeah and then so
people sort of wonder how we you know
the swimmers still manage to break World
Records and it's you know we've even the
suits have gone back to the traditional
so it is it's the training methods it's
being able to I think that the coach
swimmer relationship now is so different
to say the 50s and the 60s where it was
kind of everyone did the same thing
there's almost a survivor's a survivor
yeah yeah that's where it was announced
forming yeah so now it's you can really
you know I think a bread Hawk who's
obviously swam for us right now coaches
at Auburn you know he's he's being able
to pioneer that a bit further as well
and you know everyone's just the
attention to detail you know from
everything from you know if you know the
nutrition to strength training to yeah
techniques right so you were competing
in the era of the technical suit and
there's that thing like well these were
these records are never gonna get broken
yeah just they're just gonna stay
forever right and then sure enough
they've all are there any records that
still stand from that era I think there
might be a couple I think Biederman's
200 freestyle still exist but yeah there
are there aren't too many which is which
is amazing oh it is good to see no it's
good you know but it it just it begs the
question of like what is the outer
limits yeah exactly the ability because
when I look at swimming now like I I'm
like what are they like I can't even
relate to these times like I didn't
think that was possible
yeah exactly you know it's it progresses
so quickly much more quickly in the
track and field yeah started to slow
down a little bit but it's amazing the
frequency with which World Records and
swimming get broken yeah what do you
when you look at that like what do you
attribute that to I mean you kind of
touched on it a little mm-hmm
look I think the I mean we spoke about
you know the specific sort of training
approach and I think it's also some is
daunting to over
over swim as much as what we used to I
think it's become it's become more
quality rather than quantity and and you
know even even I know some of the open
water swimmers that swim you know 10k in
25k they only need really training you
know 50 to 70 kilometres a week but it's
quite intensive it's so it's I think
it's yeah I think like the quality of
the training and just periodization so
it's really well yeah and I think it's
just more I think we're I think we've
just become a lot more clever or they
have yeah I mean when I you know in the
80s it was just get in I mean we would
we be putting in 20,000 meter days with
regular like all the time you know I'm
just I just walked around like a zombie
where periodization like what is that
there was no conscious awareness of it I
need the the most common thing I'm sure
you probably remember like most people
miss their taper they would just never
come out and you know it's like you're a
whole year you know you know like you
were so tired three weeks out of try out
of trials of your mind mate but you just
you probably need another no I don't
think there was an appreciation for
recovery and like if you beat yourself
down that hard like just how long it's
gonna take for your body yeah it's a
bounce-back and I think I was
chronically over trained like my entire
career yeah yeah and it's funny I don't
know it became I don't know who let that
but I know that and you know I know that
the Russians were training a lot I know
the you know the Aussies were pretty
well known for overtraining as well I
think and I think it just you know the
would spread around the swimming pool
that you have to do this yeah yeah there
was that era in the 80s there I mean the
coaches in the US that were really
hitting that hard you know mark Schubert
was part of that at Mission Viejo at the
dick Shula Berg Paul Bergen yeah
Paul Bergen was like notorious for this
like you know there you hear stories
about these workouts that these guys
were doing there and you're like well I
got to do that you know and and there
are only a few people that could weather
that so I didn't excel at that exactly
but now with periodization and rest and
being very specific about what you're
doing and why you're doing it's like you
don't just jump in and go all out and
set
solutely yeah what about the strength
training regimen look I think there is I
think the jury's still out on that I
think there's anyone really yet to nail
that in terms of what is what really
what really actually transfers into the
pool it's such an you know the the mass
of water that we pull through the water
and the hand being accelerated through
the movement rather than you know doing
a doing a seated row is not quite
doesn't like trans women yeah so it's I
think there is this certainly a lot of
power movements that have you know I
started doing a little bit of
powerlifting that which was great for my
start and great for the starts and turns
but in terms of overall sort of you know
weight training its tool you know and I
think some of the conditioning it's it's
you know I think the core then sort of
core stuff is really important but I
think yeah there's still saw them
probably work it out I I'm used to
experiment a lot that's most things
waste experiment with yeah I think
there's still a lot that can be learned
there I mean I remember it Stanford like
Jeff Kostov who held the high school
national record and the 500 free for
like 30 years
and yeah you know one Institute went to
the Olympics like incredible distance
swimmer he could you used to like make
fun of him because he could only do like
one pushup like you literally you could
barely do a push-up you know it's like
one of the greatest swimmers ever you
know that era yeah and you're like oh
well I can't you know obviously with if
you were some of the 53 the hundred free
it's a different equation yeah it's like
why can't he do that but he can do this
yeah exactly and it's you know then
there's so many variables and in
swimming obviously you know but they
also you know we people they can't swim
appreciate that you know how important
feeling for the water is and and working
with this medium that is that way after
yeah actually work with rather than you
know push through it I work against it
so I'm yeah but you know having you know
seeing it kind of restful for example
you know ease the physique is slightly
you know now that the suits don't exist
you know I think the guys is a little
bit leaner they're still super powerful
but they're not as not as bulky is what
they were probably ten years oh there's
a lot of tall guys though yeah it sounds
like that guys are bigger in general
it's bulkier but yeah I mean I remember
watching the 53 final Rio you know
cheering for for Tony yeah and I was
like he looked tiny yeah it's a tall guy
you know yeah it's you know it is it
does sort of the very I remember you
know just before my ear you know you
starboard just I like to pop on Gary
Hall you know Gary hills to short us at
six six all right yeah yeah it's crazy
man
well what's interesting about your
career is it's easy to go oh 21 World
Records like all these Olympic medals
you know incredibly story swimming
career but you know it wasn't it wasn't
all roses man you had a lot of misses
get along the way and like a lot of
obstacles and hurdles that yeah you
struggled to overcome I mean despite
like these relay Gold's you still
struggle to like you know medal in the
individual that I mean you set the world
record yeah four by 100 free relay but
like you make finals in the individual
event like yeah how did you like
mentally you know approach trying to you
know deal with that kind of thing and
why do you think you struggled in the
individual events when the relay is like
you know went so well yeah okay I was
definitely I'm to this day oh my oh my
relay splits are definitely my you know
my but my best blatem I think
psychologically I I was sort of I knee
up I definitely put pressure on myself
to perform and realize but I don't know
if it almost like I felt like having the
camaraderie of the team it almost
deflects some of that and you know I I
thinking you know as well as I said I
had a very sort of simple approach to my
swimming eyes to pretty much have one
strategy and and used to tense up a
little bit and you know I never
progressed too much from heats to finals
and you know and yeah I think so I you
know as soon as you tense up a little
bit in sprint it's you know it costs you
so you know I was able to win a few
individuals sort of big mates but the
one you know obviously even leading you
know the hundred fly with about 10
meters to go and then being touched a
forgetful silver and
same with a hundred free in Sydney it's
it just sort of yeah we'll sort of I
could see that those you know there was
some bad muscle memory those coming in
creeping in and some of those races so I
think 98 was a success because I hadn't
created those some of those bad sort of
patterns and how much does you know the
external pressure play in I mean it had
to be so heightened in Sydney yeah it
was definitely hearted and and because
the haunted fly was towards the end of
the program was they seeks and I hadn't
won an individual and I was sort of you
know and I had so I'm a pretty bad hate
and so I you know the pressure was even
greater
yeah so I'm an incredible sort of 85 to
90 meters better but unfortunately they
don't hand out the medals then so yeah
but look to be honest you know I've had
some amazing races where I have handled
the pressure so it did it um it was yeah
because of my you know being able to
stimulate myself so quickly behind the
blocks and sometimes I would over
stimulate and and and go over the go
over the edge sort of but yeah so there
if I look at it you know my downfall
sometimes having that ability to
progress in terms of time from hate the
finals what is your like sort of mindset
approach to to you know gearing up for a
race like do you have a ritual or how do
you like you do visualization like what
was your practice look I was very I used
to try and warm up as close as possible
to the event so I pretty much I would
get out of the and there was I was very
I was very routine driven so pretty much
from the moment I walked through the
door I had the set routine it was very
dynamic and active warm up so dryland
and getting in the pool and pretty much
was but it was pretty intense it was it
wasn't very long but I would normally
you know it's from a lot of pace and and
pretty much from that point going suit
up and minimize any time where I could
sort of here I get distracted or but
yeah so for me the approach was really
just to not to overthink that's why I
try to if I had a if I despair and a
half I would probably swim that race
about a hundred times in my head where I
try to have the routine just kept me
moving through and and getting to the
blocks without - without overthinking it
and you know playing the race in my head
and I've shown me the downfall right I
got you are you motivated are you
somebody who's motivated internally or
externally like are you thinking about
how to have your best performance or are
you thinking about how to beat the other
guy look I think most of the time is how
to get my best performance it's almost
how to put it there I knew how to get it
how to put that performance together
could I because I've done it so many
times it's almost just hitting a certain
number of keys that I had in my race so
you know my my breakout and my
underwater kick was obviously one of my
strong points my breath control on that
first that he made is I'm approaching
the wall correctly then you know so I
had a number of keys that I try to hit
and it's I used to focus on noise and
when I was distracted and when I wasn't
hitting noise they're not stop thinking
about the other guy look at my shoulder
and that's that's times but either I
goes you know it swung over the top of
or whatever so I think it's like it like
with anything that clear my head was
before the race is the better the
outcome on so yeah it's interesting and
swimming because it's it's you and the
clock and you're in your lane and you
have a choice whether to look over to
the next guy and see what he's doing or
not yeah and ultimately it just comes
down to you putting in your best effort
and yet at the same time it is a
competition
yeah some people feed off of that they
want it you know and when you were
swimming butterfly like you're breathing
to the side yeah you look like a Mel
Stuart yeah yeah use the first guy that
you know so I mean was that a conscious
thing like I want to be watching what
the other guys are doing or definitely
fishin see the efficiency near intronic
capers and then pankratov did it after
male Stewart and then you know obviously
I am you know adopted it as well it's
more just keeping the body nice and flat
you know Michael Phelps and Ian Crocker
they kind of man was a bit higher but
mark will just you know keeps a really
low body position you know with a flat
breath and
I was able to do that with turning my
head slightly big time became a little
you know became habitual after all right
yeah so - so - around 2001 you start
having these injuries right kind of sets
you back so you're like I couldn't
figure out like did you you still start
you were swimming you swam through 2007
yeah yes you kind of struggled right
yeah absolutely problems yeah it's it's
funny that we're sitting here right now
because that injury that actually
ultimately you know cost you know my
career not cost my career but I retired
because of it well I broke my ankle when
just before the Fukuoka World
Championship so we were playing some
basketball to warm up before before
since she's never played basketball I
know and you know that that sort of
followed you know that led up to have
causing some issues with my lower back
and I had back operation at the age of
the following year and then you know
that led to you know being off balanced
and that created some more pressure on
my shoulder and then you know three
shoulder operations later I qualified
for Athens in in the relay squads and
swam all those but you know I never had
that sort of individual success that I
had prior to 2000 not 2001 right right
yeah there was a yeah it was it was
probably you know and mentally there was
a really tough time had to be yeah I
mean I you were I mean it was held were
you at that like 2006 2005 yeah 2006 or
20 I you know still in game like it
could still be you know crushing it out
of here at level so I would imagine that
was frustrating so you retire but then
you you you then you try to make this
comeback for London right why would you
do why what inspired that look for me um
fitness and exercise and swimming is
still a big passion of mine I still love
to do it and I swim more on the open
water these days but um you know I
always feel better after I don't know I
was started I actually did a few crazy
things I did a couple of venture races
down the Tasmania which is you know the
probably the coldest rugged place in
Australia was a week-long sort of
adventure racing and
and I did a bunch of runs and swims and
got on the bike even I was lot skinnier
but and I was still in reasonable shape
and you know I started having a family I
had two kids at the time started my own
business and nothing look good it was a
couple of things why I wanted to prove
to myself that I could still I was still
in good shape I want to see how fast I
could swim with all these different new
variables in my life but then I also
wanted to kind of show my kids you know
I set an example of being able to
achieve a pretty high standard of my
sport and in it you know was a bit of a
dare initially in a kind of turf pretend
to this 18-month campaign and you know
it ironically I end up swimming the same
time as I did other trials at what I did
in my last made when I retired so I
managed you know seven years later on a
planet I maintained it off five years
later I get back to similar level so
unfortunately we had the birth of you
know James James Magnussen's came came
through and Cameron McEvoy and those
guys started going you know in the in
the low 47 you know I was I was no near
that thing
yeah place but that takes balls to give
it a girl like that yeah we're expecting
a third baby at the time that's probably
easier to be in the swimming pool that
change nappies and training is very
simple yes monk-like existence exact
everything is like organized for ya you
know absolutely you know that's you know
that's then I was the thing that I
realized you know I had started and
funny business you know had this growing
family all these variables still
swimming and you know people say how did
you manage to to swim so much and how
did you stay far okay so I'm like I wish
I all I had to do now was just a lot
easier than well one of the things I
think is really interesting about your
story and and perhaps unique is you know
that between you and Ian Thorpe and
Grant Hackett I mean you guys I mean
it's you guys were super superstars in
the wake of Sydney like you know
American audiences you know I don't
think can really fathom like I said
earlier like the extent to which you
bikini you were just
thrust into the media immersive way and
that's a very difficult thing to figure
your way through yeah you know and you
seem to be somebody who who figured that
out like and I think it it seems as
somebody who doesn't know these
individuals and just as kind of looking
at it as an outsider looking in from
10,000 feet you know that's something
that that I think really you know
probably took its toll on on Grant and I
mean like they've had their sort of very
public you know and of struggles with
trying to figure out you know who they
want to be and you know where you go
from this place where like you said
everything's taken care of before you
you know exactly what you're doing and
then suddenly it's like a free-for-all
and a freefall like okay what do I do
with this now yeah it's definitely been
a very it's not just swimming I think in
and it happens here in the states I
think with our identity as athletes are
so strong and you know people reinforce
that and every opportunity they have and
and then probably further for guys like
Ian and grant and you know they reach
their success like in one the final
Freestyle World Championships when he
was 15 like my oldest daughters 12 I I
can't imagine her going to watch an e
well Jim yeah so you know and he became
you know like in obviously there's so
many artists yeah yeah yeah exactly and
you know and and I think yeah and then
in definitely struggle with that there
was a lot of pressure on him and the
expected level of expectation so I think
it's just realizing that identity it's
that swimming identity even though it
will live on forever it's only temporary
and having sometimes a fear of that
transition into life after sport is you
know it can be can be daunting and I'm
only been finding your place in life and
and what what do you actually because
you're so good at swimming what's going
to replace that void and what's better
yeah that's gonna help you figure that
out I mean you know when everything is
being taken care of for you you know
it's like what do I do now like your
whole life is premise Don okay I'm gonna
be on this podium at the Olympics in
Sydney but there's no thought that goes
into what happens
the day after that yeah now it's sort of
the guy I've been fortunate enough to
work with a group called the the chosen
experience and they always sort of talk
about purpose and intention and and you
know looking after all these different
areas of wellness of its spiritual and
emotional and environmental social so
it's sort of thinking I think when you
you know you when you're actually in
that swimming bubble on the sport bubble
you're kind of taking care of and when
you come out of it there's a lot of
areas of that wellness that fall off
especially social socially and I do
something for turn easier is your family
that no longer exists
you know you've you know spiritually
swimming is very meditative I'm sure you
probably agree for me it's the most
meditative exercise that I can do you
know yeah so from an ER from a fitness
point of view and you know we're talking
about nutrition and everything was gone
all in place so you have to start until
you find that those sort of dimensions
how you gonna be able to fill them and
and it takes takes time and some people
do it better than others yeah I think
that and I've mentioned this in the past
that that you know sports organizations
whether it's swimming or the NFL or the
NBA or the NCAA and whatever specific
discipline you know within that needs to
have organizations or like governing
bodies that are charged with helping
athletes make the transition into
civilian life I mean it's the same with
like a soldier coming back from a
deployment well yeah there's a sense of
confusion you know it's like well this
was my career now like that snap your
fingers it's done yeah and you're just a
normal person and that can be very
destabilizing for a lot of people and I
think the higher you've you you know the
the higher your achievement the more the
more kind of challenging that transition
can be I mean obviously you have the
opportunities and cool stuff comes your
way but trying to figure out like well
Who am I like am i I'm not the swimmer
anymore wait who like a passion well
yeah I put this energy that I had for
this Drive you know how do you suddenly
reprise replaces dry they
and you know you see most people it's
swimming on you know I like to run too
many swimmers that actually never you
know don't done someone because it is
such place such a big role you know
probably more symbolically than anything
but it is yeah it is quite tricky and I
think it's better than through the NCAA
system because of the education that
that provides them with you know the
athletes but in Australia I think we've
struggle with you know certainly you
know the athletes aren't supported
financially from from the sport so they
I need to find careers and then that
becomes a you know it becomes quite
daunting on them yeah yeah how is grant
dealing are you in touch with him yeah
he spent a fair bit of time with Michael
Phelps yeah and you know certainly and
he's been his back he's living in
Melbourne he's working in corporate
finance again so again for him the
physical exercises plays a big role so
now even though he came back he miss
London as well but he's still back
exercising and you know it's got a good
routine and see I think he's back on
track uh-huh so you knew that you did
you always know that you wanted to be an
entrepreneur when you were swimming were
you hatching your plan for how you you
know I had obviously had a good sort of
example with my dad being in his export
and import and he sort of did a lot of
trades and things like that so I should
have had I watched him do his thing but
I didn't have a tertiary education most
of that you know most of the guys you
know went to uni or whatever I sort of
fell out after them for my first year so
I'm but I you know I I had to realize I
want I've been exposed to branding and
marketing I've been a product for many
companies in the past so I had a little
bit of insight into what it takes to
promote and and and and and sell
something so I'm here the the
opportunity came about when there's two
companies within a couple of months that
approached me to endorse the skin care
product so I thought there must be
something in that I'll just so I did a
bit more research and that the skincare
market in Australia was definitely
growing especially for men and here so I
sort of you know did a a four business
plan and a half
little paper and and spoke to a few
different people and then pardon the pun
but took the plunge into into becoming
it I wouldn't call myself an
entrepreneur but yes yet I think you are
asking yeah why not why yes I look it
was a you know as a comment was
incidental sort of the way I fell into
it you know being assumed oh no you have
to wash it yourself from the from the
chlorine and you protect yourself from
the from the other the harmful UVA and
UVB rays so I sort of had a little bit
of insight from my history and I had to
apply that into into life of the sport
yeah I mean we just walked around with
super dry skin in green hair exactly so
then so you start this company milk yeah
which I like I don't know why but like I
didn't even think about it until like
yesterday I was like oh that's Klim
backwards yeah that's so obvious right
it's a great name thank you for a line
it's cool yeah so we you know like we've
initially we just had skin care products
for men and um as you said you know with
guys and Jim generally in Australia in
the u.s. is still you know there's still
need a bit of prodding when it comes to
you know the self maintenance and
looking after their skin so I wanted to
create products so they were easy to use
multifunctional affordable but guys was
so cool like they still were pretty
would be proud about having them on the
base and in the bathroom so I'm I
created a really simple sort of range
but it wasn't smooth sailing that's for
sure I met a few costly errors and you
know and you know obviously I think that
was probably as much I think isn't the
business for there's been much more
challenging challenging than swimming
why there is a lot of things that are
out of one in you know like even when
we're talking about you can controller
which was pretty much everything any
other way exactly and even even then
you're trying Co do you think you can
but but you know in business you're
dealing with so many different variables
from you know retailers to manufacturers
to find stakeholders accept whatever it
might be
it's so vast and and and then people are
just easy actually the liaison with and
dealing with people and daily basis and
it it becomes that becomes a skill you
know how you manage those situations
what did you learn from your swimming
experience that does translate into
being successful in business yeah I'd
say that's probably like four or five
key sort of learnings that I I'll take
from it the first probably that sense of
sense of team so I've you know our
business is very much a horizontal
business we don't have not very
hierarchical at all so you know making
sure that culture within your businesses
is right and it doesn't have to be a
business could be any to be a club or
organization so I think it's you know
people that enjoy coming to work and or
having things in common or having even
having things in common but common
values so so that was for me it was
really important nothing that that was
what made the other student seem so
great it was almost like this unwritten
grade that we had we had no idea what
there was but the camaraderie yeah
exactly to learn show innovation to I
think obviously something that as you
touched on with my stroke and the suit
and I think always you know like if you
know we came out with some great
products or was selling okay but you
can't just rest on your laurels so you
have to innovate for hunting constantly
and I think knowledge as well I was I
think when I was swimming I think I had
about twelve of probably double thick
books like this literally I would log
every stroke every session the hell well
so all the sessions I would I wouldn't
even need to write you know write it
down on pool deck I remember pretty much
everything that we did and I would I've
got about years I said a dozen of those
books so I think you gain knowledge
about yourself to then make that the
decisions with with training etc so in
business too I think it's really
important to know your business and are
your numbers so then we can make better
decisions if we're investing money in
certain areas and marketing etc so and
then now we can you know now I guess in
swimming people can get information
about other swimmers a lot easier than
what we could but yeah so
the business world we really try and tap
into you know d'Arthur about a
competition knowing knowing your
competition is really important as well
I'm not sure what else well I would
think I would I would think and I'm
probably projecting but you know the
mindset that you have to have to be
competitive you know at the level that
you were and swimming takes a very sort
of singular you know focus and ability
to kind of hone in on a goal and like
work your way towards that right and so
obviously business is a little bit
different because you have all these
people and personalities and all of that
it's not just you right and as a swimmer
you can be kind of a control freak going
this is what I'm doing yeah you know all
that kind of stuff yeah so there has to
be some aspects of that that translate
into your like okay like to be just to
be determined like this is what we're
moving towards you know but then also
having to let go of certain things that
were important in swimming yeah to let
other people in delegate yes yeah yeah
it's yeah it's almost like you you know
I was being empowered to do what I was
doing I was able to do in the pool verse
I think in in business it's almost me
empowering other people to either coach
yeah so a little bit so that some and
look as I said I've had some great
coaches in my career so I've been able
to fool them all back on that as well
but think and then just the other thing
or just remembered it's just the
relentless nature of running your own
business it's very similar to to
swimming and and sport where you
definitely have bad sessions bad swings
but isn't the ability of come back
coming back the next day no matter how
bad it is and you know you might you
might show up and not the best mood but
he's still sure yeah yeah but so that
was yes it probably doesn't my key
learnings but and so now help you oh you
got your shipping in countries all over
the world right like are you yes yes
yeah so we're not within the way only in
on Amazon in the US but we're we're sort
of our focus is sort of Australia in the
proximity to Australia so all the Asian
countries from China to create to Japan
and Hong Kong and Singapore so I really
sort of our products Len and it's
really well through especially the baby
range which is all natural and I'm sort
of really sort of simple and and it
seems to be going really well too into
that region so but I think you know our
culturally we're so similar and the
lifestyle that's where yeah so there's
there Melbourne Sydney etc but I can see
it doing well here and I like like it's
a you know it's it's clean and it's it's
like minimal in its design like it's
just very like simple in kind of a
beautiful elegant way so that's cool so
that's your main thing right I know you
do these retreats - yeah yeah it's an
experience it's actually good because it
helps me to you know I sort of
facilitate some of them I'll do some of
the the goal-setting workshops and some
some water skills and swimming etc but
it also helps me to recalibrate every
now and again because you know we're so
again I know what what the tools are for
me to be the most effective person but
sometimes you know in life that you know
I need to get when you get busy or you
know there's things that don't always go
your way so yeah so chosen has been a
great way to meet amazing people meet
successful people from different walks
of life but then you know do things that
are really good for yourself spiritually
mentally physically as well so I enjoy
that I stood you know enjoyed talking
through the team working with the same
team I worked with him in the lead-up to
Rio which was unfortunately wasn't in
great games for us but you know it's
great to see these you know the
youngsters that are I wonder if I was
that mature when people looking at me
back then but in almost the way they
hold themselves and with all these extra
distractions I think that they seem more
professional than what we were back yeah
like they come out of the womb now like
media trained because everybody is a
public personality now yeah it's
believing the awareness that young
people have around that is interesting
but it's also like it's so distracting
you know it's so easy to to fall into a
you know social media hole yeah rather
than do the hard thing that requires you
to turn the phone off yeah you know yeah
absolutely yeah so look I think they
yes I still enjoy working with those
guys but it is tricky actually because I
think I'd just say the other day I still
enjoy you know I enjoy being on this 2
gram every night thinking what other
people are doing and you know sharing my
feet my stories especially you know with
if it's something cool so but I do you
know when I have a digital detox at
chosen or whatever it might be hard to
appreciate the other side as well yeah I
was looking at the website for chosen
and you get there's a lot of trips yes
well you know you've got all of them
happening all the time oh yeah there is
there is a bunch there's a you know
there's a bunch in Bali Iceland is a
very amazing location I just came from
Guatemala I was there last week and I
was there as a guest so that was was
nice to take it take a week off for
myself and to recharge a little bit
bedtime yeah New Zealand so those are
the four iconic locations yeah it's
clear they also tend to have volcanoes
and you know I don't know what else but
there always seems to be in a very very
exotic kind of pretty rugged environment
and I want to go to Iceland so bad yeah
never been have to get you there when
you look back on your your swimming
career you know what do you like what do
you think you were able to do that
others couldn't are like what can you
know what do you attribute your success
to beyond just sort of train you know
the training and whatever god-given
talent you have like do you I know you
you mentioned being an innovator but do
you think there are certain things that
you were keyed in on that others weren't
that allowed you to get that extra
advantage to see yeah I think definitely
my the innovation in my stroke
definitely helped me a lot because I
think if I hadn't had fine found that
that destructed that really worked well
for me I think I'm not sure where I
would have been I think I was I think
that was the key but I think almost that
I had a really really sort of strong
drive from for my sport from a very
early age and I think that I think
growing up Eastern Europeans or the
background and but almost like people
asked me where did you have it
I don't know I just I just had yeah it's
something that I this purpose that I
wanted to swim you know so I think that
was months definitely an advantage and
and I think when it when it did come off
my mind said was really you know I was
able to you know I was pretty strong
mentally when I you know at most most of
the time it was obviously if you are I
wasn't but so I think even you know my
mind said put together with my purpose
and then and I guess you know with you
know with the new strike etc I think
those three things did you ever think I
mean you're you're a Polish citizen
right yes I'm from Poland yeah I
probably could have yeah I know but I
couldn't wouldn't feel right you know
especially after so much time and money
invested by this come back up to
luncheon London though you know Sarah's
doing so oh you know a bunch of guys
that are in the hunt fray and funded fly
so probably wouldn't have been that easy
when you look at at what Michael Phelps
was able to achieve and the impact that
he's out on the sport like how do you
you know conceptualize that like what
does that mean yeah look I was lucky
enough to be in Rio and see his 20th
gold and also you know see all his swims
and raced him a bunch of times as well
so you know I've realized how hard it is
to come back and I mean just to come
back but to come back and dominate I'm
especially and and he's been you know
and that I guess in the dumps a little
bit when it came to you know you fell
out you know if a lot of people fall out
of love with him and and he was able to
I just you know I think it you know I
could see how how important swimming is
to him as a person and you know he it
did definitely he had that read the
drivers probably ten times greater than
fine as well but I like to see that I
like this story because it it did sort
of you know he did the career did take a
downward turn but he was able to bounce
back which was it was an amazing fate
for me but just his his you know his
ability just to be able to come back
from race after race I didn't once once
and once and ideally the longevity is
unbelievable and I think it was it's
only natural that
something's gonna break along the way
like you can't maintain that yeah 20
years you know yeah and so you know
shocker like you know that there are
gonna be periods of time where he
doesn't want to go to the pool yeah yeah
that has to be the case in order for him
to be able to continue and perpetuate
yeah yeah and I think it's super brave
how he's kind of come out and and spoken
publicly about the mental health issues
and yeah I hope that he does more of
that because I think it's so powerful
yeah and could be transformative for
other people and yeah it's amazing how
you know it could have gone left you
know he could it could have gone
sideways for him even with all the
performances just how he was acquitting
himself in the public eye and then for
him to like pull it together and we
transcend that and to become this you
know this this this person that he is
now yeah that's quite remarkable yeah
it's great the same in being he's
expecting his second Bob soon and you
know he's a he's a you know he's found
he still seems pretty fit I think I know
he's obviously something stored there's
that he left you know he left free I
just I don't think what I think is any
more room on his chest is there like
over exactly but you know he was I'm
Hindman Buffy and you know from familiy
actually watched him swim I saw one
session actually which I was grant
Hackett Ian Thorpe and Michael Phelps
training together on the Gulf Coast one
then it was it was so amazing they had
all the guys that were actually in the
pool swimming with him West just got out
and watched them because to have the you
know probably the four in a three of the
greatest freestylers and and all
swimmers of all time to have becoming a
head-to-head it just became like a show
so it was it was a great pleasure to
watch him swim and swim in the same era
but just you know it's mental toughness
is probably thing the thing that stands
out for me especially the last one which
at the Clos was the Korean champion and
that was yeah you don't you don't you
don't pay that guy needed media training
because that's the last thing that you
say to Michael
should want to lose you know I don't
know what came over that guy if anything
one thing that gets Michael like you
know how to bed in the bar and and I
think you know we'll be seen the impact
of him for for decades to come
yeah like the inspiring young kids and
the next generation of swimmers coming
up I mean it's it's it's gonna be cool
to see kind of what he does next yeah
yeah absolutely
he seems to like golf let's talk about
like what Fitness looks like for you now
okay like what's your what's your
typical routine I mean you're still
super fit yeah I do I probably did two
or three kind of structured modified
crossford like sessions pretty intense
sort of circuits and then I probably do
two two swims a week they're pretty
pretty crazy between 2,000 and 3,000
meters or just two and it's actually
that's my real Morel solo time I really
enjoy that and then and then that other
incidental exercise you know surfing and
playing with the kids and that sort of
stuff so I probably don't get more than
then five structured sort of sessions in
the week but that seems to be you know
with work and three kids etc that's kind
of manageable at the moment right and
yeah I mean you've been able to keep it
together do you look you look like
you're ready to go right now
if you got up on the blocks right now
what would you throw down 104 I think I
would probably go close to 50 to 53 yeah
I'm glad I but you couldn't know that's
anyone off you know I fly my show there
or something like that yeah it's funny
how like all these devices now are on
the market where people can wear you
know earbuds during swimming and listen
to stuff yeah that's the last thing I
want to do yeah yeah and I even try that
for a while but now it's even yeah just
that even the sound of the water just
rushing pasta is
you know I can almost hear you know you
didn't definitely hear breath can hear
heart so for me like I appreciate
something for different reasons now
completely you know I swim with my kids
and you know it's it's a skill that I'm
so glad that I've got so it's much safer
in the pool that I'm online that's for
sure
yeah yeah so so where do you see this
all going just continually grow milk
yeah what's next for you yeah for me I
think you know with the business has
been going in the 10 years for us you
know I think it still has some great
potential and looking at you know
different partners along the way to to
try and get it to a global brand I think
we're still you know a small fish so
yeah you know putting putting that
together but still I think for me you
know spending time with my kids and
seeing they kind of I've got this six
nine and the 12 year old so sorry I used
to travel a lot between Melbourne and
barley and sort of for me it's actually
finding a little bit more you know being
more grounded it was sort of yeah pretty
pretty hard to juggle everything I went
through a divorce a couple years ago as
well and that sort of took a bit of a
toll on me physically and mentally and
just trying to be everywhere for
everybody so I think it's been a pretty
interesting time just to prioritize
health kids you know my partner des rois
balanced all that stuff man absolutely
you know and then coming from swimming
where it's just like I can train five
hours a day yeah you know eating nap and
all of that and they're like there's
business there's kids there's you know
we ever like trying to apportion your
energy across all of those things and
and being somebody who is driven who
wants to excel in all of those areas
like it's it's a hard equation yeah it
is and it's sort of um for me as well
I'm probably I'm not I wasn't great at
saying no in the past and then probably
I don't
I think it's sure I had a better I'm not
I don't really like letting people down
in terms so when people are ask you to
do stuff though is probably cool stuff
too that you want to do you know like
it's you know and look I've been very
fortunate because people have done
me a lot of flavors so I sort of feel
like I have to repay them but yeah so
it's definitely I think you know I'm in
a phase in my life where I'm just you
know much better prioritizing mm-hmm
well thanks for saying yes to this
thanks for your great self to be great
to see me when you when you look back on
your career are there things you wish
you had done differently or
any regrets that you have or do you feel
like you know what I laid it all out
there man yeah I definitely look I
definitely in terms of my approach and
my training I definitely didn't leave a
stone unturned in the porn in the
training pool I think probably I've you
know overcoming some of those hey I
wouldn't say you know like we were
talking about is just slightly mentor
sort of toughness and write some of
those big individual events but I
wouldn't say it regrets is probably
being able to work on that a little bit
better identifying that early in my
career but um you know I think I was I
certainly you know I've certainly did
the work I was I got so much out of the
sport I should be great great friends
and and it gave me an opportunity you
know to move forward and in life as well
so I'm pretty pretty pretty happy if you
were if you were gonna coach young
up-and-coming Olympian swimmers what
would you focus on or where do you think
like the white space is like what do you
think like when you see these kids
coming up or you see what coaches are
doing do you see like oh why why are
they doing that what they should be
doing this or do you look at it
differently or no I think the guys are
pretty on the money pre-revolutionary
already at the moment obviously they
keep improving um it's a really good
good question I don't know I think
they're you know I think what I've liked
and and those of some of the Aussie guys
are still they're still being kids you
know a lot of them when I was growing up
and I loved the sport and I remember you
know coming back from one of those
sensations in Perth and I saw you know
hockey and therapy and the guys on the
PlayStation it's just being there still
15:17 and you know I think probably if
anything it sometimes becomes too
serious and you know and so yeah I think
having it yeah you're having fun with it
I think you know if it gets too serious
too quickly can you know you can burn
burn out but terms of training methods I
think they're you know on the money
that's certainly better than what I was
today so I can't tell them what you know
what to do anymore
I wonder when who the next huge star is
gonna be I mean the the shadow of that
that you know Phelps leaves is so
massive like who could ever possibly you
know eclipse that see some guys like
look low yeah yeah I have the potential
to make well think Caleb obviously dress
or was all right that's what I meant to
say yes yes did was just like short
course worlds or something like that
he's like breaking World Records in
breaststroke yeah I think you know I
think we found him to be honest like and
he's doing in events by the hundred
three hundred fly medley he's you know
so versatile you know be interesting to
see how if he can repeat that in in
Tokyo I think you want five gold and the
world champ so I'm yeah so he's he's the
next one to watch for sure yeah it's
pretty exciting man yeah so if if if a
swimmer or any athlete for that matter
young person who's trying to excel in
their sport is listening to this and and
and maybe they don't have the greatest
coach yeah they don't have you know the
Australian Institute of Sport yeah but
they're trying to figure out on their
own through vodcasts and the internet or
whatever like how to be the best athlete
they possibly can like what can you
convey to that person yeah so you know I
think obviously I think we all
understand that in sport there's only a
small percentage of athletes if they win
that that ultimate gold or the
championship or the world record etc I
think there is so much more than you get
out of the sport that he felt lone about
yourself as well so I would encourage I
mean my kids I I'm creating any sport in
particular but they still do it they
still
you know I think the routine is really
important the structure is important and
I think the ability I think it prepares
you like that toughness there being you
know being able to bounce back in in
life in general it's it's it's what it's
all about you know I think it's we you
know this certainly adversity is around
the corner and that's how we managed
with that and I think for me sport was a
great great a vehicle to learn my sort
of prepare myself for life lessons in
the future so yeah I think you know
they're not just physical physical
development so I think if I would say
I'm definitely have a crack which is
another bit of analogy saying but you
know just being able to just just
perseverance being in persevered I today
you know that's yeah keep chipping away
I think for a young person it's gotta be
hard in our social media fuel culture
because you go on Instagram and and
everything looks easy and sexy and
romantic it's like it ain't Stu to be
great at anything is the most unsexy
thing yeah yeah because you got to show
up every single day
yeah like slog through the mud and it
sucks ya know and you feel like and
that doesn't translate well you know on
Instagram it's hard yeah you
know and it's about consistently showing
up for whatever you care about yeah yeah
it's finding that you know we've words
keep coming but obviously finding the
drive for whatever that purpose is and
you know so and it's funny because
sometimes in my squad I've had a couple
people living in my club squad the
people that are most driven and most
passionate necessarily weren't the best
swimmers and in a growth you know some
of the best ones probably had the most
talent and things used to fall into
place for them but they're ones that
tend to we used to fight the mice were
the ones that probably didn't have the
most talent when I so yeah I think I
take that guy any day over the super
talented guy who doesn't show up for
work out yeah exactly exactly because
that B&I prepares you for life off this
board yeah well were you one of those
sprinter guys that like
flagged off like it was always a
sprinters like perk out again yeah you
know I was actually when it came to
training out it was one thing that I
really enjoyed and I I was you know it's
always pretty very punctual used to get
get more used to cheat a little bit when
sessions when that coach was you know
put on some crazy sets and you know just
maybe cut the warm-up down a little bit
what was the hardest set you ever did I
don't know if I'd it was mine my knee
just lactic sort of tolerance stuff so
you can really sort of as simple as
doing you know three max one hundreds on
you can do Italy simply on ten minutes
and then just that well that or but you
know doing you know we did six as well
650 s max on on two minutes as well so
but it's it's it's just getting race
ready I'm so you know I didn't do a
great deal of high-intensity you know
short rest training because of my events
but that lactic tolerance was work was
probably the yeah yeah alright man we
gotta wrap this yeah thank you what do
you what else you have going on here in
LA so actually I'm here supporting my
partner Desiree she's got a fashion
label so she's got a bit of a publicity
event tonight so it's called swf
boutique so I'll be uh I'll be probably
the Instagram husband an article but I'm
yeah just making my way back home from
Guatemala so I'm and enjoying this this
Chris whether you've gotten oh yeah and
are you going straight to Bali I go I'll
go to go to Melbourne first and then go
back to Bali
I'll be back in Bali next we'll hook you
up with my friends in Bali I'd love to
meet you thanks I appreciate it if
you're diggin on Michael the best way to
connect with him milk and co.com is your
skin care line you got like nutrition
products and stuff like that we I mean
we've done anymore we used to have some
protein products but time we basically
it's good skin fitness range so we've
got it
chlorine wash which is great for summers
a sunscreen a bunch of other products
for a for active people and it's a
natural products for babies and some
more pampering products for women's it
system is that and the men's line is
called it's called clean women yeah and
then the other well it's funny you know
the blokes out there they didn't kind of
like he like yourself didn't didn't get
the idea that milking how I was clean
but they couldn't do that math you know
it's funny when I you know when I did a
couple of corporate keynotes and they
and I tell them the story that it you
know I've just looked in the mirror and
no I mean obviously I need my surname
was it was milk fact words for many
years but yeah it doesn't always jump
out so we did a bit of study on our
products and I'm guys thought it was a
little bit too feminine not quite bad
enough cause you guys man yeah we just
[Laughter]
cool and then you're out Michael Klim on
Instagram and Mark Willem one yeah yeah
yeah any other Showzen experiences
coming up yes we got a bunch of chosen
experiences with the coming up in in
Bali so if you guys want to check out
chosen the experiences calm there's all
the dates and in locations but yeah come
and do us I've got a swimming week
coming up in July so there should be
should be good with a bit of skill work
with a bit of surfing a fair bit of a
little bit of gym work but it's it's a
pretty fun way that's awesome
and it's chosen experiences calm yeah
all right well closes down by saying my
man Dan McPherson says hello and I told
you earlier like Garrett Webber Gail
called me yesterday out of the blue who
also you know won a gold medal in the 4
by 100 free relay and a subsequent
generation in an epic that was an epic
race as well and I and I was like oh I
got I got Clem coming over to the
podcast didn't know I was like do you
know him like what should I talk to him
about he's like I don't really know he
probably doesn't remember me
but he said that he was at a meet in
know what meat it was they tell me I
can't remember Montreal some world
championships or world university I
don't know something like that and and
he said that like he came up to you to
meet you because you were like a big
hero to him and you ended up giving him
like all your Ozzy gear and he's like I
still have it he's like I'll never
forget that it was like that's all so he
was like a big hero Thanks it's nice
when that you know and it when you get
that feedback after minis it's because
you never know who that person might
reign I turn turn to or what what effect
that might have on their on the three
Orleanians up getting a you know winning
that really really really eight alright
I was amazing race I see Jason Lezak so
thank you like let's do that it's
probably the relay race of all time a
little second second thank you thank you
[Music]